oh damn it she's away so this ultimately
[Music]
actually talked with the people you say
talk about my being offended for you
[Music]
one two three
man no we have to talk about how this
movie isn't good he'll end all female
superhero yeah try not to show the fear
inside
you
[Music]
oh yeah that's a nice so that is nice
look at you I don't know what we're
doing but apparently I get a plot
wondering happen let me know a wonderful
woman oh yeah
do you understand I was waiting to braid
your hair into the baby hoping you stay
yeah yeah that even mean
but having our drop doing whoa wow that
was great you are excited
maybe yeah way to do or don't Joe Oh
like the caveman thing one cool let me
real fast in this country Union you're
going to be curved like you be sitting
down my lingering the thorium just like
co2 gets on and run wiser so I get from
my yes no we're going to go ahead you're
used to quite upset so yeah pretty much
went up as soon as I say aggregate echo
you sit down I'll say full but that's
our meeting this vlog ago okay okay red
shoes balance at eight here okay
why is that ready and sit down
Oh
long ago the god juice told the god
Aaron's not to try to overthrow him
everything pretty except he was totally
reduces like bitch I am Jews and Ruiz
arrogant ass out to make sure it's my
comic monster like that we never can
take over his creation beyond on as well
it destroyed the Electoral College and I
get to be a name of them when I grow up
no because I hope you can pray and
brought you to life
really no but in your than telling you
where maybe really come from but I want
to be a lot yeah she's my sister look
perfect on this one go on it I like
Alexandra's you did help is is that try
one does the whole way here but you want
to fly so the budget had a beard voice
crap holy that one I'll probably go back
and forth between but but yeah well what
is your answer
but the is really really good ok I'm
still in the Superman outfit I will get
my black super heavy Batman outfit
perfect paper that's Frank are you going
to like me never evil it's not bad who
goes to the beach wearing fur that I was
earlier
um it looks sad no there's why he was
not wearing much else other places it
can't look like I'm gonna panic I can
work out your outer skin feeling your
ass I won't ever be Arthur Arthur yeah
oh don't care oh boy have you watched my
show Mentos is motorized I'll go my way
couplet down backwards
turbulence on your flight foot no I know
it I am like it look really delicious
y'all know really does must kill it now
Malcolm be sure to get a shot of holding
the camera
oh are you really doing that we got
that's it it's going to be interesting
to see Trevor
oh I mean like I don't already think of
liberty but Elias before it's like a
clear-cut okay like with that like uhmm
I am lecture let's believe I never even
is like yes the way you want to like
down like the
okay and and then I'll say I'll take
both and you go like this in the door
comes down and I'll say you know boom
swing the sword back and you just like
you know okay good doing it darn when we
parted I know it is good on action a
little too much on the offensive because
she's coming to use of everything the
kind of life yeah deep end
I'm go ahead series should I just tell
you where I'm going with right right
left right sure down right left okay get
where you guys are going good
we're all holding on to those yeah oh
[Laughter]
I'm getting out of the tube and it is
your look is it getting me okay Oh Who I
am is that upper the book all right yeah
okay
do you have older a little more that way
a go okay ready and one two three man no
we have to talk about how important it
is a just that if you get in man yeah
and they put a migrant
[Laughter]
we talked about half this movie isn't
good hills in female super connection
where are we looking exactly sorry uh
yeah we look like right now at our you
know I'm like very happy out that
marriages okay okay Amanda I guess I
know it one two three
man no we have to talk about if this
movie and then good it'll end all female
superhero movies yeah all right where do
man yes ready and one two three man yes
and what on the way out since I'm are
yes you say vision uh Jason Jimmy how
how lucky in the press okay okay this is
Jenkins what there's really getting is
it but your father was bozos make an
anti send this process is a light show
right so for any pretty much what it is
is you're holding a anti-feminist thing
you want me to grab it you want me to
bite and I look up and I say what the
hell is this you say pops movies nothing
that's enough and we need to talk about
it and then know both of all the blah as
they forget I'm not blowing your for
your complain bait you say this so much
didn't get needlessly at soda pops no
yes okay what is only I look and I
grabbed it and I like you holding a
little bit I September family and as a
feminist Ally I'm tickling forehead yes
as a hundred man in this but as a some
madness now because I'm tired
ya know you keep the defendants good as
a permanent I'm deeply insulted well I
don't they look pretty good
no no I'm being offended for you yeah we
we need to and then like the whip the
last is gonna come in with you I just
run off that way there's honestly one
tape oh okay the more you get out Yahoo
boat here we'll get my crew over here
you go out in the side of room yes I
don't find you dude
I don't know what there you go oh my god
okay
pretty much so use your doggy hey
everybody come in I'm Malcolm color the
browser goes on refresh this whole Bank
is just like yes and as I keep dragging
to let me I didn't go home you know and
you do look each other
sure forget the button good yeah yes I
look like my desire okay now do you want
Malcolm to cross in front of them or
behind the camera oh whatever
easier however no yeah okay alright
yeah already mmm-hmm and action
I don't like a full billion
oh good when you're dragging romantic be
a little you're like really far waiting
to get out of the shop and go ahead and
sort of like just like just behind you I
have tried to pull her back just like it
off go go oh yes there so we close the
door when you're right about here well
no no I mean like in okay like I mean
we've all your baggy eyes it's not -
uncle oh yeah I feel like before it was
like really far away I'm not the pocket
yes okay okay
y'all ready and action
I can't hit my glasses over certificate
oh yeah okay okay okay blue-nose these
prepa on this oh okay yes besides the
mouth of a George haha okay uh you're
actually going to you're gonna be on the
ground you're gonna be holding the sword
and it kind of like this is trying to
keep it still she's gonna walk up she's
just going to pull it like he's like
sword out of the stone
Oh some stone your hair I agree
- yeah booyah right there was definitely
yours welcome pricing i look more a mine
is rooted ya bars on this one definitely
do you get like that just hit up so
maybe you like exchange Oh Jackie
that common phrase okay um yes
so the Paris I think what we'll do
Heiser sneak in yes yes take a look and
actually good I think 50 validated
century
yeah um
okay ready and action
great
oh one more chicken uh it's just one
dumpling it from like definitely it like
this you seen like that is great
oh yeah for sure already good good okay
and action
great one more to breathe out with any
okay okay cuz it's gonna be a pretty bad
cut yeah okay ready and action
okay yeah okay and I think nobody's
being play oh my god I think the next
one behavior is really short
okay um well happily to be is Harley
Quinn's malice and she had like Wolfe
dairy or sub every time he hit someone
if you win pool well like
that would be great yeah I ever happy
gaku um okay
general I have a fast fast thing to
shoot real fast is these German soldiers
and y'all can take a break perfect
it's the best way if you want to go like
this go for it is now you can get it
happen yeah you ever see that your
things with it I guess not
you want my crew that's okay well did
you see Suzanne Oh shed an eyeshadow
yeah oh I think he's having a fear about
living one music do you see my beating
here like my mood - no no no okay
oh let me take the Danvers soothing
thanks just a.m. pictures video game
okay I was trying to breach it you on
you into it oh my go through he did
please Steve yeah hit yes I'd never hang
up I'm like is that where when you think
that tequila me let's feel gotta movie
before Wonder Woman I just a movie chef
also had a wrap-up oh yeah yeah baby
moms on you're kidding oh really yeah
yeah a real thing people love it yeah
we get back we the girl for you killed
my clown and that's my holy shit set the
chair and I get over a businessman oh no
you have to at least have a superhero
movie for every single one of that you'd
be in a prequel to Sam yeah you know I
think I like you to get short on how
that like Eva time really I think it
worked better actually
so yeah I love you we'll go get it yeah
you look good yeah okay
symbolism Jesus I am Jesus you're
welcome Yeah right what was that but
it'd be really it could be more to it
symbolism Jesus I am Jesus you're
welcome sisters but then you know what
now like a whispering like I think I use
the whispering take of it okay do you
want the other one having a bit too
silly Indian what does oh yeah we go
okay oh okay I think the whispering
motherfuck
oh no I mean there's a woof-woof in out
it's me auntie Xue oh that's good
because you're just wait okay so this is
going to be going to take the clothes
off real fast
huh and so this is only gonna be you of
this one oh go ahead move that out of
the way and yeah and thanks Wonder Woman
you fight for my right to wear satin
tight I mean damn know everybody knows
yeah I don't think just start the review
uh all right I probably got cut off a
little bit just go and do it right again
okay right great sassy lasso lasso yes
everything's going to Carter okay
so you know what she transform she does
that well it's bad right yeah so in on
down or are they up I thought they were
are they are up yeah okay so like side
out the side yes okay yeah but she
doesn't hold the last in your hand yeah
you guys Jim was the man with the play
so I think just standing there like
heroic I think when I come into just
they're like this and I'll just look
like and I'll just yep come in here
it's your cake and you can eat it too
Jie oh really I didn't know the magic
hand or a gift is hand cake
I literally done okay you might just
play us out while I eat cake this big
can you see his hands and music it yeah
you're gonna have to yeah and your arms
extend out okay yeah there yeah okay
ah let's uh let's do this then maybe
strike we're good so I can maybe I could
just be like this I call really is an
interesting dream yeah yeah all right on
camera and you point to the diabetes are
you actually pointing to your rap good
yeah sorry
all right ready recording we are rolling
and action here what's this it's your
cake and you can eat it actually I have
soy de oh I didn't know that Yeah right
here
I mean the magic hand already gave it to
me it's magic hand I literally died
you mind if you play about while I eke a
okay you can be like alright now you
want to knock the cake out of your other
transformation works you can do it very
lightly okay again do that like hit me
everything and I just won't even react
okay
the room okay ready and action
and I take it back so I saw the cake
before okay ready okay and action here
what is this it's your cake and you can
eat it too actually I have diabetes
oh I didn't know that Yeah right here I
mean the magic hand already give it to
me it's magic hand I will literally die
okay
you mind playing about them while I eat
a good desert it is perfectly awkward
okay well what up by magic hand
Cambridge a pancake hanky okay yeah can
you would you mind taking like a half
step backwards from where you were
before so I can because you guys are
like really bunched in a mobile frame so
I'm trying to try to get that a little
bit okay so yeah I gotcha okay that's
the rules ready and action here what's
this it's your tape and you can eat it
actually I have diabetes
oh I don't know Yeah right here I mean
the magic ant gave me the cake is its
hand character I'm a literally okay
do you mind if you play us off while I
eat a Mac Mac Mac
correct yeah let's do one more I'm just
gonna say you might display that will I
eat the hand kick are you okay
so you think much of it when you're
rewriting it dance like oh sorry I know
it's funny but it's like it's hard to
say I could say it fine okay
okay right I was um we should get the
little way in a little bit more yet huh
it's really dark okay it's area get met
you're filming something over here huh
that's better okay great
now you may be awesome but you're not
eating cake with a water you may be
awesome but you're not eating cake with
Wonder Woman playing electric guitar
awesome do you want me to do any like
movement like I can go up to the top oh
I'm Jen just wrong really still okay
it may be awesome so you're not eating
cake with Wonder Woman playing electric
guitar awesome
very good not change if that is like
when she's strumming it that's gonna
pick up over your lines and that that's
going to mess with oh yeah just go ahead
and did you want to say cake or hand
cake cake next to wanted one playing
electric so you may be awesome you're
not eating ham cake you may be awesome
glad you're not eating ham cake next to
a quick I think oh okay you may be
awesome but you're not eating hand cake
yeah you may be awesome but you're not
eating and cake standing next to Wonder
Woman playing electric guitar awesome
okay thank you ever seems like a tiny
bit that way there you go okay okay okay
you're all right Glenda set and action
you may be awesome but you're not eating
camp you may be awesome but you're not
Heat you're not you may be awesome but
you're not eating hand cake standing
next to Wonder Woman playing electric
guitar awesome yeah okay just really
focus Legolas okay ready and action
oh sorry Havelock's I've never heard
Wonder Woman speak you may be awesome -
glyco offers yes'm one of the only yeah
change why we're starting what is our
it's cake and you have your cake you may
be awesome but you're not eating hand
cake standing next to Wonder Woman
playing electric guitar awesome
hahaha yeah it is
[Music]
you